my statement to someone that is the
victim of a patent troll lawsuit would
be that on you are completely screwed
[Music]
Austin Meyer is a computer programmer
and small business owner based in
Columbia South Carolina
he's also an aviation enthusiast who
pilots his own personal plane Meyers two
great passions intersected when he
created a flight simulator program
called explain explain is a flight
simulator that simulates the way
airplanes really fly Microsoft Flight
Simulator used to be the go-to civilian
flight simulator of choice the problem
is Microsoft Flight Simulator didn't fly
the way a real airplane flew so I
decided to write my own simulator like
most software developers Meyer has
adapted his application to run on a
number of mobile devices like iPhone and
Android and this is where he first ran
into trouble I was at an airshow in
Oshkosh Wisconsin and I got an email
from a lawyer I'm sorry to interrupt
your day but I notice you've been sued
in East Texas an East Texas based
company called
Yuna lock was suing Meyer for violating
one of their patents and wanted damages
as well as ongoing post-judgment royalty
which meant Meyer could potentially be
paying yoona lakh for as long as X plane
exists and is making money at that point
Yuna Locke could own part of my business
forever the stress associated with what
I believe is this absolute lunacy could
be great enough that I'm unable to run
my business and my life as happily and
efficiently as I otherwise would the
patent in question is called system and
method for preventing unauthorized
access to electronic data when you buy
an app from an online store
vendors want to confirm that you've
actually paid to use the software one
method is to create a database full of
verification codes which can be matched
to a purchase license code when a user
runs the application it automatically
compares the license code to the
encrypted database and then confirms or
denies that the user is paid for the
application this is the method that
nearly every application on the Android
Market use it this is a method that has
been in some form of use since at least
the late 1980s this is the idea that you
know lock claims down so a patent troll
is a company a person an individual
whatever who owns patents but doesn't
make anything and doesn't sell anything
Julie Samuels is an attorney and the
Mark Cuban chair to eliminate stupid
patents at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation the patent trolls have got a
business model that works quite well for
them
unfortunately they go after a company
who's actually practicing an invention
who's selling a product who's offering a
service and they say we think you're
infringing our patent and we're going to
sue you they know the right amount of
money to ask for just less than it would
cost to litigate just enough that it'll
probably hurt the target but the target
can afford it and you know most sane
business people would rather pay the
patent troll to go away than engage in
litigation
you know Locke president Brad Davis
declined an interview request saying
it's our policy not to comment regarding
ongoing litigation but a statement on
the unilag website reads Yuna Locke is
in the business of finding big ideas
look at many ideas pick an outstanding
one patent it commercialize it reap the
rewards one when the patent was filed it
was not unique idea to have been used
for seven years - you know Locke didn't
invent the patent they bought it at a
bankruptcy proceeding and so those are
two facts that you can use to evaluate
for yourself what I think about you know
Locke's idea that they're bringing new
ideas to the field most patent trolls
don't actually you know come up with the
inventions and sells most of them have
bought the patents if what we really
want to do is to incentivize innovation
to incentivize job growth to help grow
the economy to come up with newer better
products and technologies then that's
not what we're doing the economic damage
caused by so-called patent trolls is
stagger
with researchers estimating that tech
companies pay out at least twenty nine
billion dollars a year to the trolls and
that isn't counting off-the-record
settlements I will not simply give
somebody money that endorses the idea
that they should sue people for doing
something amazing and while patent
trolls represent a huge flaw in the US
patent system Samuel says that the
problems go much deeper you can't
separate the problem with the patent
troll from the problem with software
patents because there are hundreds of
thousands of software patents floating
around that are really broad that are
really vague a lot of them end up on the
market and they're brought up by patent
trolls and the broader and vague or the
patent is the more dangerous it is in
the hands of a bad actor Yale
researchers found that the government is
issuing more than 40,000 software
patents every year that's more than a
hundred software patents a day Samuels
is optimistic about the chances of
reeling it back in thanks in part to
something called the shield Act
that's a fee-shifting bill which
essentially says that in certain cases
the loser pays the legal fees people are
really receptive to this conversation
and that's great that has to do in no
small part with the success the
technology community saw in the SOPA and
PIPA fights of 2012 I think that a lot
of policymakers are afraid to end up on
the wrong side of technology and the
technology community in the meantime the
fate of Austin buyer and x-plane hangs
in the balance all I can do is put my
foot down to try in some tiny tiny tiny
little way to make a statement that it
must be stopped at some point
[Music]
you
[Music]